[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to
GameSpot's III stage we are here getting
ready for the Nintendo Direct starting
at 9 a.m. Pacific but first we want to
get together and hang out talk about
what we might see what we want to see
what we're predicting I'm your host Mike
McCarty here with Justin hey Walt
how are you d Lucy James hello and Kelly
plague all of us are pretty well-versed
in Nintendo u3 more than me so I'm gonna
kind of like run some questions by you
run some predictions things we
definitely know things we might not know
let's start off with something we saw
surprisingly at Ubisoft maybe not
surprisingly but the way was presented
Mario Plus Rabbids Kingdom battle we've
seen a bit of that where companies are
announcing games that you think is gonna
be as part of somebody else's
presentation and I think having the
Mario Rabbids game as part of Ubisoft
means we're probably not gonna see it at
this Nintendo - right but that's a
really cool crossover yeah I wanted to
talk about it because hey any conference
that starts with Miyamoto walking out to
smoke with a gun probably a cool game
and people who watch like GameSpot stuff
know I'm a huge XCOM fan and that's why
I'm interested in this because I don't
care about Rabbids I love Mario but I
thought it was the other way I thought
you were like a huge rabbit you know I
guess I'll try out this ex-con thing but
yeah so it's coming to the switch
Ubisoft a Nintendo cooperative kind of
project which is really weird and cool
there's behind the scenes thing that
went up on Ubisoft I was watching it's
crazy that project came together but
yeah we're pretty sure we probably won't
see Morton today no more than a trailer
anyway oh yeah I doubt it
we saw tons that yeah like they have
Nintendo from what I've written down
here has a lot else to show in just half
an hour for direct so I doubt they'd
waste any more on that yeah comes up for
the end like they always do like a
trailer wrapping up boy doing this or
just like during the presentation maybe
they'll say like mention it yeah
splatoon - do you think it'll be any
more last-minute stuff they'll show us
there's that pretty much just like we
know what it is we know what's coming
out soon it's like Nintendo especially
with III like I don't think we're gonna
see a lot of far-flung stuff like it was
really weird a couple was he last
the year before the year before when
they showed off Star Fox and was like
this is the first time they've shown a
game that's not coming out this year and
I think that's why they always seem to
focus on stuff that's very near-term
stuff that's gonna be hitting this
holiday so we're still gonna see
splatoon they're probably going to
announce something that maybe we haven't
seen yet some new guns or something like
that yes what it's more you all play
right what is like can you tell me what
the difference is it's just more of
splatoon one or they're huge differences
with this
there's dual wielding a building gun
yeah switch now yeah
it's hugely different well show you
today that would get you even more
excited because we release in a couple
months
they have amiibo support and I can have
like Pikachu or Zelda as a skin you play
Zelda in Skyrim yeah see something like
that Passion Pit
I want those kinds of because they had
amiibo support for splatoon one but it
was mostly to like unlock challenges
yeah I'd like to see that extended just
attuned to ya something a little
different I'm a huge shooter fan Kelly
you are as well
I did not so I'm looking forward to too
because I want to everybody that tells
me shooters are great also says it's
really a novel take on the genre it's
cool it's yeah it's Nintendo's kind of
unique version of that I like the team
aspect and I think the the biggest
problem I had with splatoon is that you
couldn't really communicate with a team
unless you got on skype for like discord
or something a mixer you know with the
switch there's the potential phone
support stuff that's like I'm kinda
pointed by that but we support like you
just literally call you it's like you
can just use your phone like but you
they have this little plug in then you
plug that into your switch I'm like oh
yeah I use your phone
right yeah so get a monopoly on phone
communication yeah I'm taking over the
biggest thing through me would have been
a better way to communicate with your
team because it is very important in
splatoon yeah but I mean we'll see it'll
still be fun I really liked the first
one yeah
on to one of the bigger titles that I
think everybody at the show is wondering
about super mario odyssey
you think this is gonna come out this
year as they originally said I really
hope it does they say holiday or
December I think they said December yeah
but I mean I'm at the point now where I
have my switch I have Zelda I have
Marriott and I'm just so desperate so
more so at a direct like this I'm really
hoping that they do deliver on it yeah
it's coming this year fine
I can play Mario on my training to work
yeah and he's that like console defining
it already has the console defining
Zelda yeah this will be the Mario that
does that right like the Galaxy or the
Super Mario 64 did do you think we'll
see they'll show off so we saw that
during that initial director showed the
switch off and Odyssey
they showed kind of you could use your
hat to platform yeah and it's also the
biggest conceit is that it's set in
what's known as new dog city it's like
an open world like you can go outside of
it right it's like yeah I was yesterday
and they had like loads of different
sort of world like at least it looks
very very different it wasn't just new
dongzi so I'm excited cuz I was a bit
like not sure how this quasi real world
thing would work yeah yeah seeing Mario
with like real looking people it's a bit
way he's skipping or something and it's
like these businesspeople
it was like a little row like to stir
disturbed isn't the right word but I was
like I don't like it
something's worried about it but yeah
they show like there's kind of a Super
Mario Sunshine s mm-hm world like yeah
so there's isle delfino is that it yes
there's like I forget what those those
isle delfino inhabitants are called but
yeah I saw them in the trailer yeah new
Dark City they're humans right like yeah
I kind of compare it to if you were
cosplaying Mario at like comic-con it
wouldn't stand out but if you were
cosplaying Mario walking down the
sidewalk in New York during rush hour
I would I would see you yeah right now I
feel like I'm gonna be out of place in
new dog city but he does go to like
other like deserts yeah it looks like a
pseudo Earth
I think yeah weird like half earth half
fantastical there is an area that's like
like super big like all the everything
is really big so it's I don't know if
this is supposed to be everything
supposed to be realistic I'm curious to
see more of the worlds because the new
dunk city stuff is a little I'm like
this
interesting yeah that's what I play when
I play supermario de see I'm expecting a
real-world equivalent like that's what
for the realism yeah that's what looks
important I assume for you guys as well
it's like fallout it's like going into
this real world and getting to be a
plumber yeah kills jumps on his hat yeah
there better be a skill tree did you say
Skyrim and fallout are real places
[Laughter]
I can't wait to live in them in VR just
like my real world Kelly do you think
it's gonna come out this year I would
really hope so I mean they announced it
far enough in advance that I think it's
in the realm of possibility goodbye you
know yeah 100%
okay December still like they originally
announced holidays I don't think they're
gonna delay this one like they need a
tentpole
winter game it's gonna be super mario
ought to see we've known about this one
for such a long time I think this is
gonna be what they hang their hat on for
the holidays yeah from what they showed
it looked pretty polished and done too
I mean I don't Nintendo's not usually
accustomed to showing stuff that's janky
I'm like a few conferences this week
what about Xenoblade Chronicles 2 you
think that all is that this year's show
more but do you think they'll show
anything I imagine so yeah yeah cuz I
doubt I wonder if they would use that if
they would show any more of that to
compete with Mario I don't think it
would release this year I don't think
that this year but it's definitely
something that'll be a part of their
presentations yeah cuz that's their huge
fan favorite rpm and especially after
Zelda like taking that and those were
the not that same developers but
monoliths off the guys who helped create
Xenoblade Chronicles World yeah also
created the world for breath of the wild
like getting to show that off in kind of
a different way like it shows that
there's that fan hunger for this type of
content and so I think they're they'll
definitely have it as part of the
presentation and announcing this like
sometime in 2018 yeah and with Zelda
they showed that they can do a massive
world on the switch so people who like
xenoblade must be even more excited did
you guys play Chronicles or X I did not
but former GameSpot Stefan mucke Walton
did and he was I was talking to him
about it once and he was like yeah yes
awesome and it was always when one of
the games that I kind of
meant to get around to and I think by
that point my Wii U was like in the
corner of the cupboard not plugged in
completely unloved so I'm excited for
this too yeah Pete Brown our reviews
director like won't like stop
recommending that franchise to me all
the time yeah I always get recommend it
to me I was in the same boat where my
Wii U by the time I would have been
getting around to it was like unplugged
and not really in a lot of use kind of
using my 3d s a lot more at that point
so I'm excited because I have my switch
with me always like I just I'm really
excited for these fan favorite games to
make it to a console that people really
like well and having those big
experiences on a handheld platform and
not having to be stuck in front of your
TV
that's so much nicer but I could never
sit in front of my wii u for that long
yeah yeah you were talking about well
this isn't endo related but monster
hunter world was showing it Sony last
night and that they then afterward you
got that email saying it's what Xbox one
Xbox one PC as well yeah so you no
longer have to stick to your 3ds not on
the switch though there is a monster
it's coming out on switch once or
hundred generations which right probably
I mean especially after seeing monster
hunter world it's a little bit
disappointing because like this is the
monster hunter that looks so good
monster hunter world I thought that demo
was bad though you're bad bad demo like
what it's far too long like this is I
want to see less of this game I wish
they would stop showing it I want to
seen so many things going on I hate it
I'm like alright Fire Emblem warriors
yeah anything on that today some Musel
game so I actually really like missile
games and I like Fire Emblem so I'd be
interested to see kind of what's going
on with that you kind of you can kind of
imagine what any Warriors game would be
yeah you don't really need to see it
that's the thing is like yeah so I know
they take time to show something else
yeah in this presentation but I am
curious at that favorite warriors yeah I
just think it's not something you'd want
to show during a 30-minute presentation
at e3 yeah I
babblin those games I guess but what was
Justin's laughing at me no no I I agree
like I don't want to spend too much like
the things that I think is most
interesting about those is when they
take like this Alda franchise like that
was an interesting take on who so Dragon
Warrior probably not as big in the West
for that kind of audience yeah what
about the shin megami tensei that they
announced during the initial Nintendo
Direct I don't think we're gonna see it
this year I think they're gonna I think
we've seen that taste of it we've seen
that tease and I wouldn't be surprised
if they hold off on it it's just not
even mentioned because we don't even
know the full name or its subtitle yet
right yeah yeah I mean I really want to
see that actually after playing persona
5 which is my first persona which is
very different than shin megami but yeah
but I actually want to see that now I
would love to have like a really unique
RPG on my switch I would just love if
they ported persona 5 over that's you
know god those are words yeah be dope
goose the dag Macbeth okay try I haven't
done I haven't even been persona 5 on
ps4 yet I haven't either I just you know
when I'm playing mice which are just
like this is exactly how I want to play
games because I'm so nearsighted I wish
everything would just get ported over to
the switch yeah so many more games yeah
what born to which doesn't even exist
yet so that that's not me announcing it
when I'm not supposed to this doesn't
exist pipe dream Pokemon Ultra Moon and
Sun you think could be some okay stuff
happening on the direct I mean they had
their Pokemon direct you know if they
would do anything for ultra sonic ultra
you have to imagine that's why they
showed the Pokemon stuff maybe unless
they're gearing up to do stars here oh
yeah but it still seems unlikely which
is annoying because Sun Moon came out
like when last year yeah but yeah yeah
and I'm not exactly sure I need a
slightly different version of Sun and
Moon and I really I really liked those
games I thought they were a super great
take on Pokemon and like added all these
things that were
both good for casual and for hardcore
like competitive players but I don't
know why you would need another version
that's like the alternate universe
version those Sun and Moon so I'm I if
they did anything like Pokemon on switch
I would actually cry the Pokemon game
that needs to come to switch a snap oh
snap that's what I was gonna say um cuz
what snap came out hot when I think I
was four at the time so I was I think I
was four like ten years ago then yeah I
don't I didn't poke him on sunny moon to
begin with I thought they were kind of
boring
I liked $90.99 Pokemon snap
Wow so I was uh doesn't matter we were
just imagine like actually like
something with motion controls that
feels good yeah
motion controls aren't bad like the
motion controls I think in most cases
feel-good are right right they don't
feel bad but I'm saying like something
that warrants the use of it would be a
perfect news for me it's integral to the
experience which I don't think is always
the case but yeah we I don't know if
they will devote much time to Pokemon
after that no not after not after its
own director yeah and then what about
Zelda DLC so so it's been my guess that
they they will because Nintendo tends to
announce something and they drop it
during this week they said over and over
again that the DLC is coming this summer
I would not be surprised if they show
off the Zelda DLC like here's a little
bit of what this looks like and goes and
now you can play it right now yeah it's
kind of like a one-off thing they just
say we all freaked out and start crying
and I've left my switches in the hotel
room I could get it a bunch of us
brought our switches to our studio here
in case they do this talking about it
but it sounds good I mean we've talked
extensively on our live shows about what
this is gonna comprise it looks fun it
looks like something don't pull me back
into it I do have my switch here I'm
hoping they I hope they do release it
because that'd be great but at the same
time because of I don't have time to
flare it but I brought my switch and my
3ds just in case yeah for people
watching
at home I'm sure that would be nothing
but great to be able to jump back into
Zelda right now
you think they'll show off more of the
Nextel the DLC at all I think three plan
right is it later on this year there's
one in the fall I think I feel like
that's something that they would hold
off and do on their own kind of like
they did with Pokemon like here's our
dedicated Zelda direct for e3 because
it's so short they'll focus on the stuff
that's more near em like maybe they'll
mention it and like hey don't forget we
have this coming up but I don't think
we'd see much of it yeah and then I do
want to talk about Skyrim on switch
they're not gonna take time to show this
because 19 other times maybe they show
it with a different passion pit track
over it or maybe Nelly Furtado makes a
comeback she never left okay don't call
it a comeback anyway yeah you can't hear
it right now but if you didn't see this
during up it says those presser take a
walk my passion is playing over this now
and then of course link comes in and
then this weird monster wearing a mask
of link appears in Skyrim somehow got
the Master Sword it looks like he's a
high elf I want to get really geeky
about all this yeah he does look like a
high elf frog you guys think about this
these motion controls something I will
never I will yeah let me let me let me
preface I don't mean to sound negative
it's cuz I'm absolutely gonna buy this
on switch yeah probably in VR as well
cuz I'm this yeah this is why they keep
showing Skyrim at every e3 because
because no I had I played on PC I didn't
need to buy the definitive edition and I
bought it anyway on Xbox like I get
achievements
oh no I played the original Xbox 360 and
I bought the definitive edition on ps4
just so I could get achievement ya the
trophies ya want to play one that's
gonna probably have not as nice graphics
like this won't be the difference oh I
mean it looks like even when you're
watching the Bethesda show it looked
like kind of interlaced and it did look
junk you like who cares I can take
graphics I'm excited for with that it's
the fact that much like Zelda which
looks great on a switch it's the fact
that yeah I could take it anywhere with
me it's also the kind of game I don't
need to
you know remember what I was doing last
time I could just jump back in and yeah
find my way and figure things out
yeah also don't need to pay like a ton
of attention cuz I've done bleak falls
Barrow like six thousand times so like I
know what's going on it's mostly just I
want to be a sneaky Archer again so yeah
it's not like something that's going to
demand a lot of my power
yeah like and I don't mean that in a
negative way no I mean Skyrim is my like
go-to game when I'm sick yeah it's a
relaxing just sort of like wound around
and kill stuff experience you don't get
on Nintendo consoles for such a long
time especially yeah like getting to
take that portably like a massive
third-party title
what about 3ds I think so much for that
yeah I mean the focus has to be on
switch because that's their new big
console but they're not going to ignore
3ds especially the new new TD 2d s the
new tedious the new TSX 30s XL t to 2d s
XL maybe they'll show it so we can know
what yeah do you think they'll they'll
probably devote some attention to maybe
a new 3ds title I think they'll mention
a couple games but what we also have
Nintendo doing what Nintendo does which
is here's our 30 minute presentation and
then several hours of us playing games
in the a treehouse stuff yeah and
they'll have a lot of time to talk about
3ds 2ds gets weird why is it it's weird
to call something a 3ds game when you
have a 2d asset system that is created
just to take away the 3d yep yeah but
yeah though I think they'll mention a
few bigger this is and this is also
their chance to announce surprises games
we don't know we're coming up though all
announced had a little bit of time to it
and more time at the treehouse for 3ds
stuff surprises for 3ds and you can
think of what do you want well the only
thing I really really want yeah if you
ask me go down god I was really worried
I think it's gonna be on switch Virtual
Console we can talk about that later I
really want to Layton ya know there's a
leak coming there's the lady Layton oh
yeah yeah this is the time to show it
for 3ds owners it's it is one
my favorite franchises and so that'll
definitely be a part of the presentation
at least in a small way yeah what
they're like Nintendogs let's go would
they doesn't end logs back on 3ds like
on another portable or would they take
it over to switch though I feel like
that might be it that could be a switch
I'm just trying to think like if you use
the the joy Cohen's like I'm gonna wash
my dog the really immersive experience
you can sat on a train like about to do
something bad and be an enabler Animal
Crossing when it's so bad to get the
mobile game like yeah they announced
that a long time ago it was a be part of
WWDC I've regretted so hard
erasing I accidentally erased my save in
new leaf and so I just like haven't been
able to return back to it and I need you
know how many hours was in that new leaf
save um a lot probably like three
hundred five hundred yeah hundred did a
lot of bug hunting on that I live all
right I'm gonna go to switch predictions
like crazy dreams and stuff well
actually no first well you've met you
mentioned Virtual Console do you think
there'll be anything focused on that
today I they need to address it at some
point yeah so the thing and they just
really don't have a good solution
they're gonna they have to talk about
how this Nintendo system that you're
gonna have to pay for is gonna work and
they've already said that when you pay
for this like what is it twenty dollars
a month something yes you just get
access to all of these NES library of
games but we still like we've spent a
lot of money or I've spent a lot of
money don't include me with you games I
don't expect that I'm gonna get access
to those in my switch but I would love
for that to happen like I've already
bought these I want to play them on
whatever console I have my Nintendo
account on yeah yeah that's the thing is
like if you've bought like Super Mario
they're like oh the original like eight
times and you shouldn't I just don't
wanna have to buy it again I've ya
bought so many versions of it monthly
price
to play it again yeah I would I would
actually be okay with a monthly price
that includes the entire library evening
yeah that'd be awesome
yeah that would be like sprint endo
that's like yeah but it would that also
include the the pain to go online stuff
as well as I think if those were to
separate payments going out of my bank
and I would know yeah it sucks because
the switch seems so tailor-made for so
many old-school Nintendo games yeah you
have this pretty sizable handheld screen
right in front of you and that makes
sense for so many 2d games even like I
don't know I could see playing like
Metroid Prime on my switch but I do want
to I do want to get on to like
predictions for the switch itself do we
have any crazy things we didn't talk
about me talking about Metroid yeah it's
been such a long time I don't think it
would be a big part of the presentation
because again they like to focus on
stuff in the near future but we one
thing we haven't seen at this e3 is the
one more thing walk up the stage as just
like a logo or a really quickly the
trailer comes on this could be
Nintendo's chance to be like one more
thing
Zelda like samus aran's mask just comes
on screen and that's out 2018 do you
think they would go like do you think
they would given and go 2d Metroid I
almost just called a Metroid game a
Metroidvania do something new yeah I
know prime I think is such a beloved
franchise it would be really interesting
to return to that especially after
metroid other m do that well yeah we
have a poster that hanging in the office
i haven't even noticed it I blocked that
game out of my brain entrance to our
office it's it's the Clementine oh yeah
Walking Dead and then metro oh my god I
definitely like Wes world that like yeah
there was nothing that no yeah I erased
that yeah otherwise it was fine but
that's if the story was just so cool
that's the thing yeah um I don't know do
you guys think we'll see any sort of
Metroid I hope I seriously hope so yeah
yeah I had a Donkey Kong yet either
what was the last really good one was a
tropical tree yeah yes right yeah that
would be awesome
cuz I were you we you too okay so they
have an answer to I mean not just
Virtual Console but these games that are
digitally available on the Wii U console
making that just cross compatible with
the switch would not only increase the
library of the switch fivefold and give
access to people who didn't buy Wii U
because that's that's a lot of people
yeah I would actually really like to see
that yeah yeah me too like like you said
ports like I like I want to play win
waker HD on switch you know you know my
pipe dream is is the Wii version of
Okami because I think that was so good
on switch not only do you how could you
use like them this you could even use it
as a touchscreen as well to paint and it
was a cel-shaded game so but yeah it's a
fix would hold on oh so beer it would
winwaker we are sorry yeah we you yeah
I'd be interested to see if they do
anything with like Star Fox because the
last I think he's as I saw after what
was it what was the last Star Fox is
your honor they would have to call it
Star Fox Redemption Fox reboot Star Fox
just kidding you fell for it yeah um I
don't know any other franchise that I'm
not mentioning that we would love to see
come back like Pikmin we were already
getting a 3ds game so I he picked on me
yo I don't think I want to see worry a
WarioWare game perfect that would I like
I just imagined like the things that
you'd be able to do with your switch and
multiplayer and like taking a little
controllers like whether they do it as a
party game or just something kind of
crazy and weird that you do on the
switch I would like to see them come up
with something like a multiplayer game
outside of like splatoon like a new
multiplayer game that's not doesn't feel
gimmicky because they've proven the
switch like is great I love the switch
now that we all agree on that I wish
they would show more multiplayer cuz we
didn't get a good like Wii Sports analog
once you switch did not live up to
should not have been a game you paid for
my I think my biggest like far-flung
dream would be Pokemon Stadium SI
pokemon stadium 3 on the switch yeah
that would be grateful for multiplayer
like an actual opportunity to use like
oh you get one joy con you get one joke
on that would be hopefully better than
one to switch and also I just miss those
games so much and then having that
compatibility with the 3ds games would
also be great Pokemon 2 was the dank
McNiff that gold and silver cartridge
that you pop in your oh you have like
the little attachment that goes into the
controller yeah like put your Pokemon in
it yeah that's that is what I want get
my boy mah champ for reunion with me
what do you think I'll first start off
the show with you know straight into
Super Mario you oughta see that's what
we know is coming up that's what it's
gonna be the focus of the show and it
lets you set expectations big switch
game here's uh here's your good first
look at the gameplay of yeah Mario does
Ubisoft had a very Nintendo opening to
the show well obviously because Mario it
was the coin box but still it was a very
like quiet and then all of a sudden
something quirky came in yeah oh I get
it
do you guys agree would be Odyssey yeah
that would be nice it wasn't yeah I like
I said I'm curious to see what they'll
show with Odyssey that can really I mean
I'm already gonna play it but yeah I'm
curious if they will show off like the
the flood gun of the same if you will
like what's the the general conceit
outside I had work exactly like his
that's what jumps on it and so it looks
like I was watching the game if I turn
again yesterday it looks like he can
throw it and then I guess you tap the
button again to make it stay where you
need it to go to platform off it yeah
cuz I don't think I think you can throw
it like um like the boomerang powerup in
Mario Kart it seems like it just goes
for a long time but then when he was
using a platforming it looked like he
could pause it right in the middle of a
gap Oh manually control everything yeah
that's what it looked like any right
yeah we don't know for sure but like you
can throw it like an enemy to kill
goombahs and stuff yeah yes we should be
getting into the Nintendo Direct in
about a minute
there's no countdown yet so I wanted to
ask do you think we'll see
like in terms of outside of Skyrim any
other third-party titles that they'll
take the time to show here or it may
even throughout the week maybe any
announcements like other third-party
titles coming because it for the longest
time to intend Oh has been you know not
much third-party support what about the
the new use of thing they have to switch
they had to switch in that when the toys
to life thing o StarLink think yeah that
game is weird
it looks cool it looks fun I think I
don't mean this is an insult but I think
I would like it more 10 years ago yeah
yeah who knows maybe that will come no
anyway but minecraft maybe yeah yeah
alright we are gonna go to Nintendo
Direct
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the game is fun the game is a battle if
it's not fun why bother if it's not a
battle where's the fun it's a test that
you pass or a quest that you fail or
race against time fun and battle always
lock together but the game is also
something else
it's a journey a passport to new worlds
maybe even an odyssey a look a feel an
exploration close your focus and open
your mind yes the journey requires the
right ticket and that ticket is Nintendo
switch but in the end it's not just
where you can take your game it's what
your game can take you so let's go
story goes that when the world was young
everyone in our rest lived on the world
tree together with our divine father the
architect
they called that paradise Elysium
[Music]
[Music]
you're
blade as the driver of the aegis
can you take me to easy
I mean let's go to Elysium I'll take you
there myself
we'll show you Michelle you want me
Empire made
[Music]
now that you have come this far there
can be no
you
sore
I'm guessing your home is amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
his blade he calls Pilate
[Music]
if you know
to show it not with words but with your
own strength everyone
[Music]
sometimes you need a hero a sword swings
fire will be stone-cold hero with an
insatiable appetite
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nothing hi everyone I'm Shinya takahashi
from Nintendo I hope you've been
enjoying the journey with Nintendo
switched so far when I found out that
Nintendo's switch is being accepted by
video game fans from all over the world
as a home console that could be taken
with you anywhere I felt so relieved
take switch outside come together and
share the experience this idea was how
we hoped people would play with Nintendo
switch but people are coming up with
many creative ways to play in all kinds
of places in many more ways than we
expected this summer Nintendo and his
third-party partners will release many
multiplayer games that can be played
anytime anywhere and with anyone we hope
there will be many heated competitions
that will be ignited by Nintendo switch
now we'll continue our look at even more
new game worlds for Nintendo switch but
before we do there is one announcement
we'd like to share from our very special
friend please take a look I'm sue Nico's
Ishihara from the Pokemon company just
the other day we announced that pokken
tournament deluxe is coming to Nintendo
switch this is the latest version of the
premier pokemon fighting game two people
can dive right into battle using two joy
Khan controllers so you can experience
heated Pokemon battles with just one
Nintendo switch console there are some
fresh additions including new Pokemon
and this deluxe version of the game will
be on display at e3 for attendees to
play I have one more announcement Game
Freak has begun developing a core RPG
Pokemon title on Nintendo switch and may
not release for more than a year but we
hope you'll look forward to it all the
same in the meantime let's enjoy this
year's e3 she heard us on thank you very
much we heard that the Pokemon series is
being developed for Nintendo switch what
kind of Pokemon game will we be able to
play on Nintendo switch I'm looking
forward to it myself at this year's e3
we're mostly showing games that will be
released in 2017 but please know that
here at Nintendo were working on many
forms of entertainment that can only be
made possible on Nintendo switch we hope
you look forward to them as well now
let's continue on with the journey with
Nintendo switch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mother's in danger
you two must keep going no I'm coming
with you
[Music]
I am Mars the Prince of all taya we've
come here to save you remember that you
can rely on your friends we are with you
get it together you two if you can't do
this who can
you fought your way this far there's
nothing you two can't do no matter the
danger we can overcome it if we're
working together alright let's move out
working together we can finish this
[Music]
hi there
I'm the Legend of Zelda series producer
Eiji Aonuma you may have already heard
about it during bethesda showcase that
was held a few days ago it was announced
that select Zelda items will appear in
the Nintendo switch version of Skyrim
I'm really looking forward to exploring
Skyrim with the master sword in hand oh
when did this Master Sword get in my
hand next up we'll take a look at the
DLC packs for the Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild let us take you on a new
Hyrule adventure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what did you think I actually have one
more announcement that I'd like to share
the four champions that appeared in the
Legend of Zelda breadth of the wild will
be available as amiibo the zora champion
MIFA the Goron champion diruk the Rideau
champion Ravalli and the Gerudo champion
herb osa
you'll be able to use these four amiibo
in the Legend of Zelda breadth of the
wild of course you'll be able to use
these in the DLC packs that you just saw
so please look forward to them this
changes the game
travel the world bring people together
play anywhere with anyone if video
gaming is a journey then anywhere has to
include a stop right here in LA during
e3 this is Magic week where booths buzz
and channels glow where the game worlds
you've heard about suddenly spring into
life and this summer a new kind of
heated competition ignites right on
Nintendo switch it takes off later today
with the splatoon 2 world inkling
Invitational which brings teams from the
Americas Europe Australia New Zealand
and Japan to see whose colourful skills
are the best
tomorrow the pokken invitational will be
held you might recognize some of our
eight competitors who'll be duking it
out in heated battles later on Wednesday
we'll see eight players throw punches in
the fun and competitive game arms which
launches later this week four of our
players will be pros and the other four
will be III attendees who rise to the
top by battling on the show floor if
you're going to e3
we hope you'll accept the challenge and
no matter where you are be sure to catch
up with Nintendo treehouse live
93 for all the details and news about
Nintendo switch and Nintendo 3ds but now
there are few more worlds left to visit
on our journey before we land in the
booth let's go Ubisoft is proud to
announce its new Rabbids game my
oppressed rabbits Kingdom battle and it
will be developed exclusively for the
Nintendo switch the rabbits crazy
personalities and unpredictable behavior
will shine as they arrive in a
reimagined and twisted Mushroom Kingdom
they would surprise you in this tactical
adventure filled with combat and
exploration
Myo Ernie's friends would join them in
an epic quest to put the kingdom back in
order we can't wait for you to play the
game on August 29th
[Applause]
[Music]
on behalf of everyone here at psyonix
we're extremely excited to announce that
Roth le is indeed coming the Nintendo
switch we know that both the rocket
league and switch communities have
wanted it and now we're going to release
it
complete with cross network support the
lets you play against opponents on other
platforms the switch version will have
all the features and modes we've
released thus far plus exclusives like
local wireless multiplayer Mario and
Luigi hats for customizing your car and
new exclusive cars we'll talk about
later this year look for rocket League a
Nintendo switch this holiday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with me girls with me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to Nintendo
treehouse live at e3 2017 we're back for
another year we've gotten a lot of great
game content to show you and a lot of
special guests running by as well but to
get things kicked off we're gonna take
another look at Super Mario Odyssey just
saw the video in the spotlight it's
gonna be coming out on October 27th
really soon and we're gonna take a look
at some gameplay I'm Sam from the
treehouse driving by my colleague from
the treehouse Rob Rob and Scott on the
end and we have some very special guests
with us for this segment we've got the
game's producer Koizumi son and the
game's director motocross on thank you
both so much for joining us today
Before we jump in there were a lot of
really cool reveals in that video and I
think folks are gonna be really
interested in all the different
directions that you're taking this game
but at the core there's really kind of a
driving philosophy that you've got going
I was worrying if you could tell our
viewers a little bit more about that
video imitator like it that's all many
go
first could I just ask you is there
anything you saw in there that
particularly surprised you're interested
you I gotta say the first time I saw
that t-rex
Mariama dubinina yeah no better no
kunitake no kioku yoshi imma see so we
have a theme of going on a journey in
this game but we're also trying to give
the player a lot of surprises that I
think the dinosaur is a little really
big surprise for most whatever CDs if
they're not module
I know Morty Rossano Macario Sara tokars
McCoy I said there is more carry on
you can't even order a mother
schoolteacher mama curry I didn't scream
or okuni Taavi no rocky tibideaux smoker
a monocle meat I know they're I know
what rocky to attend oh okay I came also
does he visual more so does he a tax on
some economist we also want to balance
that feeling of surprise with some
emotional resonance giving people
something that's familiar that's
attractive that's really cute from the
Mario series and bounce people back and
forth between the familiar and the
surprising yes or a OneNote I gained
through Camino Authority a no play
system
it's pretty much down there it's it's
mr. so we've come up with some play
systems to get that cross as well so
it's not just a look and feel but a play
experience also and I'd like to turn to
mr. motsek ER to explain that a token
say Grabow co-
takea Malloy did a lot of cueball cancer
so the kind of overall story of this
game is you know you're going around
you're throwing your hat you're taking
over different enemies and objects and
you're traveling the world while you do
that and we talked about surprise before
but basically the unit of surprise in
this game is those power moons those
always equal a surprise so you go around
you know you throw your head at
different things and control enemies and
you find things that are surprising and
that gives you a power of its gameplay
Rob you're gonna take us into a new Dark
City I am first I'd like to take a quick
look at the Odyssey for which the game
is named it's the ship that Mario uses
to travel the world and it's powered by
these power moons so you keep needing
additional thresholds of them to get on
to the next Kingdom and just to show off
a little bit of the new moves obviously
there's the hat throw you can make it
stay in place which is sometimes
valuable it can grab things for you
there's two kinds of coins which we'll
talk about it a little later on actually
there in that whole dialogue box we saw
Kathy oh yeah yeah
Kathy is both the red hat that he's
wearing and also in his native form he's
a white top hat and so one other move
that's pretty cool is this circular
throw not everything but let's get down
into the city and as you saw in the
trailer so there's the the capture
mechanic lets you take over things it
also lets you do fairly exotic things
like turn into electricity travel to
water so how did the capture mechanic
come about little cup job to your
shields I'm not
Suzette Kosaku a possible cuidando cause
she started chemo or a toasty pair of
sweet peas so when we were making this
game before we started out doing with
making just a huge amount of different
gameplay prototypes and this capture
action was just one of those prototypes
so you know it was just one of the ideas
that came up but we worked on it for two
or three days and it just instantly
turned into something that was really
fun and we decided well okay this should
just be the center of this game
I loved how much it encourages that
exploration and experimentation that I
think the mario games along these lines
are so known for when you think about
Super Mario 64 Super Mario Sunshine here
we've got so much stuff that just looks
interesting and you're wondering okay
what will happen if I throw my cap at it
you never really know what's gonna
happen - you want to try everything just
to see - do you see all this name yeah I
definitely open people while they're
playing this game they just forever have
of everything and right now normally if
you were following the story path of the
game you'd be talking to Mayor Paul Dean
who wants you to recruit musicians
there's one there but we're gonna ignore
that right now because there's lots and
lots of things gonna be armed following
the main story of the game
like possess rockets and turn into
rockets
actually that's an interesting note
there so you mentioned that Mayor
Colleen and I think our sharp-eyed
viewers will notice that some of the
street signs are references to some
Donkey Kong characters we've got some
interesting red girders going on here I
wonder um I'm gonna cross on if you can
tell us a little bit more about the city
it's got some interesting backstory
dorita don't keep common care of
something
Nani kana gave the Kincaid up the name
new dog city probably leads you to a
couple of hints but we can't get into
too much of it I like the shirt you're
wearing by the way let's see we need
please look forward to hearing more
about that and this is interesting here
where we see I mean really throughout
new dog city nicely throughout the world
we've got these really fun playground
elements where you're bouncing on things
you're jumping on things you're swinging
can you tell our viewers a little bit
more about how you came up with that
kind of climate
Buddhist art teach there at all Toby
hunter HDMI you don't know at all conk
you on the money
so now going back to that prototyping
process I was talking about before we
obviously create lots and lots of
different ones lots of different game
ideas and then next what we think about
is where to place them within stage so
you know we put in the stage we like
combine it with different art assets
like kind of like real real things to
see what it might actually look like a
work in game and then try playing the
post I know you don't like it I didn't
know this so those are any so we need
and then you know obviously out of that
like different things come up like oh
maybe we could do this a little bit
differently maybe this could actually
work like this instead and then we kind
of add that to it and the process just
continues from there tuck scene and go
jump the city no more no Super Mario
Sunshine about totally die on the show
that is so irritating and so you know
you saw before you know we were able to
jump on top of the taxi and that's
something that was sort of in Super
Mario Sunshine at time so in that way
we're also getting hints from past games
can I quickly interject that in the so
as I mentioned the goal right now is to
recruit these musicians when I was first
playing this game for a feedback report
for the development team I could not
figure out how to get to this guy on the
top of this building he can just barely
see him he's a speck right now in that
triangular building and the way I
eventually found to do it was to take a
real surprise and you know when you when
you saw that report from me you know
what was was that a problem to be solved
was that a cool thing what was that like
ammonia wanna and see it on the whole
Food Show
a Carini and alternate from abandoning
AutoCheck at Ignacio to kite America
saga so let me take a commodity
thundershock alright so you all done
this way little more your joke over
there put insult or what about this yeah
I did read that I didn't know you're
gonna be playing that right now I also
know the real way I'm just another way
[Music]
but you know you found your own way to
play it and like letting users play
around with the game and find their own
ways of doing things that's something
that you know goes way back in 3d Mario
in Super Mario 64 and sunshine as well
so this is actually one of the two
kingdoms gonna be playable on the show
floor the show floor course isn't open
yet so we don't have folks playing the
game at this moment but I'm really
looking forward to talking to folks
after they played it because I think
there's so many different ways to
problem-solve and find the boonies and
these kingdoms I'm not even sure folks
will find everything over the course of
the show but is gonna be interesting to
find out how different people approached
completing some of these objectives but
the game encourages it so much
experimentation because you're kicked
out of the level when you're everybody
every time you find a moon there is no
reason not to investigate every little
thing you can see that might be an
interesting there's no time limit
there's no there's no disincentive
lots and lots of cool stuff whoa yeah it
is a very interesting change that adds I
think to the immersion in the kingdoms
when you think about Super Mario 64
Super Mario Sunshine whenever you got
your whatever the collectible objective
was to play on the game you're playing
if you get bumped out of the area and
you'd have to come back in but here
since you're not gonna get booted out
the kingdom there's a lot of
encouragement to just I'll go check out
that weird thing you saw on the horizon
because you can still continue with
whatever your another reason to explore
everything is that there's very little
distance there's very little punishment
for dying I just lost 10 coins and
there's lots so and I get to try again
right away
it's also worth mentioning that the
bullet bills here are coming out with
visors on so they cannot be captured
until you knock their hats off an enemy
with a hat is the scariest thing in this
game fashion is very important got to be
conscious of your head where is not my
day for this challenge
that's right third time's a charm right
yeah and if you think the first you
don't succeed give up on the third
attempt
I'm just looking at the space where we
saw other sections of New York City I'm
looking here I'm just so impressed with
the texture work that's been done and I
feel like every time I see me build this
game more and more of these textures
jumping out at me it's it's really fun
to see personally we have some other
segments later on in the in the stream
that are kind of highlight some
especially pretty areas and following to
be my fingers and toes crossed yes one
thing that we haven't mentioned yet that
we probably should talk a little bit
about is the fact that you're playing
with joy bond with the wrist straps
attached just and that's a really
fantastic way to play this game and of
course supports pro controller and other
controller options but you can do so
much with the motion controls and
throwing Kathy feels very intuitive yeah
I've been have switched to it a
different section of game where I show
the sand world there's also playable on
the show floor but I do love that as
you're experimenting I think we'll see
folks doing that on the show floor here
so many of your gestures will affect how
Kathy moves the while you're holding the
joy kata the wrist wraps attached you
really want to just try moving your
palms in different directions like okay
- right
up and down out but I was really
impressed by how well that
implementation was put into play we are
so here we're in the sand Kingdom in the
town of Twisp Audrina and there they
have a problem now because it's all
frozen everything is cold for reasons of
course that Mario will eventually solve
you actually hate - soaking second we
can show his alive animation oh yeah I
think he's distracted by the by the
local dancing around but I think it's by
himself than he really shivers so let's
see here what's the one thing I did want
to show off is so as we mentioned
there's two kinds of coins in this game
and for the I believe the first time in
the main main line Mario series you can
actually five things with your coins and
I wanted to ask the developers how that
came up you know that currency should be
worth currency
Monday pointed to be honest I high so we
wanted you know coins to be used as
coins in this game actually use them as
money and you know I think I think
you'll agree you know if you go to you
know foreign land one of the things that
makes the biggest impression on you is
the currency you know you kind of look
at anything
wait is this is this real can I use this
[Music]
and since you know Mario was going
around to all these different kingdoms
in this game we wanted to make sure that
there was a currency free item it a male
prostitute milk ID and you know they're
a collectible items so you can use them
to buy different outfits or buy
souvenirs yeah and it's always fun to
buy souvenirs right yeah absolutely
speaking of shopping we are now in crazy
cap so there's two there's two kinds of
coins as we mentioned the the purple
ones are unique to the the local kingdom
the yellow ones are can be used in any
shop I'm gonna buy because the the guy
that at the door said maybe I should I'm
not living up for their dress code maybe
I should buy some clothes to fit in
better I'm going to buy a local sombrero
and poncho and wait to see how adorable
Mario looks
being adorable I just love the
shopkeeper yeah and their huge sack of
hats is so cute
and you can see some of the souvenirs
you can buy there that can used to
decorate the inside of the ship nice and
now I am rocking this look let's go try
that door again
so my capabilities are the same you know
I still have it's still Cathy even
though he's turned into a different kind
of hat now he can turn into any kind of
head where apparently the exotic
superpower all right so I go over and
talk to this guy see if you meet the
expectations down snappy and lively
snappy and lively I think what they had
is the one in the ponchos the other
alright and this is of course what the
goal that was working toward all this
time all these little moments of
surprise where you know what's gonna
happen I don't know why where to go to
this room so I could play a guitar
exactly so then we're gonna move on to
some more traditional 3d Mario game play
over this direction now that you are
terribly well dressed it's time to go
dismiss play yeah Prince must be on the
right track so notice that by using the
motion controls I can actually use the
little homing function on the Hat
more easily it is possible with the
button controls only but it's much more
difficult we're at the classic Goomba
yeah and let's just do a big one for
that's I guess something folks are
probably noticing here so you're not
capturing those Goomba it's not every
single enemy that's capturable that's
true um you've got to find the special
ones yeah and a lot of its having a good
eye and just experimenting a lot with
its cap I think they're a shape bigger
the ones who can capture
[Music]
some Bills of course are useful because
you can fly with them
and and now I've got to very quickly
capture my right back
I'm with bullet bills they you can only
capture them for a limited amount of
time because it's a point they're just
gonna blow up so you have to be a little
mindful of what you're doing yeah you
only got that much time with the
explosive and then almost to one of my
favorite bits in this level
oh yeah the next bit you're coming up -
yeah so this place has these murals that
look like they're decorated in this cool
old-school aesthetic and I'm just gonna
go right on in and I just look at my
costume so em where to piss on a
motocross on I think we definitely need
to hear a little bit more background
about why you added this into the game
because it's so cool but it's so
unexpected as well I think not a
community do you know how to beat
somebody so I wanted to make something
that would be sort of a contrast with
the 3d stages that you're able to
explore very freely
[Music]
you know the 2d the 2d spaces are kind
of more confined they're more precise
you you know it's more like kind of sort
of traditional platforming
and but also within the 2d stages that
you can see we wanted to have a lot of
different varieties and of course you
know what the visual is we're hoping
it's something yeah the people who
enjoyed kind of those classic know how
the games also get a kick out of as well
so one thing I'd love to show off when
we're getting out to write the end of
this space is just how much the music
changes when we're transitioning back
and forth you know we've been chatting
maybe it's hard for some folks to hear
what's been going on here but if we just
pop in and out of that warp pipe it's a
pretty impressive transition when the
music changes
but there's no warpath about here yeah
but you can now see that's more of a
naturalistic instruments so I'm gonna
skip ahead and show off the last part of
this this scenario okay
that I've only these wrist straps people
always restaurants yes it's worth
mentioning to you that we're only
covering a tiny bit of what is in this
kingdom there's so explore there's just
a ridiculous and on alright so here we
are this is much later in the level I'm
still got my snappy outfit though watch
these bullet bills transition out of the
2d and then I'm going to use one too
it's really and about the bullet bills
as capture target you'll see here when
you're trying to target for really
precision flying it's got a little bit
but it's got a little bit of a headlamp
so you can kind of use it's super handy
that's okay cuz you get to see this cute
little 2d to 3d transition with us it's
so cool
all right you guys all right here we go
and with both bills you could also give
yourself a little speed bursts as well
shaking the droidcon will let you go a
little bit further so it's worth
experimenting once you get a feel for
the timing of how long it'll last
it's kind of like driving a car it
doesn't have any brake pedal you can go
faster you can steer alright so up here
we're going out to confront one of the
brutal and folks may have seen them in
our original teaser trailer for this
game they are an evil wedding planning
firm and I'd love to hear more from the
developers about how they came to be and
what your favorite brutal is good bunny
yeah I thought it did
good fun look it goes your vehicles I
feel too steep so they you know as you
kind of said they've they've been
employed by Bowser they're in charge of
making sure his wedding goes off without
a hitch and they're very serious about
their work their work ethic is admirable
[Music]
drop the sandwich beep oh no John
abortion public failing I cannot and you
know my favorite is a topper the kind of
shorter one who has that favorite oh you
saw Cody kiddin me going on there this
is really good timing because the
character I like the most is the one
you're fighting right now Harriet she
has this great contrast between her cute
appearance and my house devilish she is
she's sort of like the tricky little
sister of the group here
our attacks are really fun to watch as
well especially when she starts flying
around and it's worth mentioning you
fight each of the brutal a few times but
they're their tactics get more and more
intense and dangerous I'll be honest
having planned a wedding last year I
would take the help of people wedding
planner yeah I mean any evil help is
better than no help and they're very
dedicated to their work and they're
willing to fight your enemies for you
and that's pretty brave oh there we go
[Music]
now she'll be back all right so that's a
grand moon worth three power moons and
there we see Cathy in his natural state
as well there is celebrating Macario
[Music]
all right so that's what we have for
gameplay for right now but we didn't
have one more little feature I believe
yes we've got some new goodies that have
turned up here on stage with us so these
are the amiibo for the game we've got
Princess Peach Bowser and Mario in their
wedding outfits and I just need to ask
you guys about the development process
for these because the the detail of the
sculpting is incredible it must have
been a very interesting process getting
these to the state they're in here
Konami possibly come on kites pretty
captain up did your this not 13 seats
mistake that mascot hi hello in there
peachy he may or Rika like you don't
think it's good thickness so first of
all you know we've got our heroine peach
and we wanted to make sure that she just
looked you know absolutely stunning
Mario more so no way today are the
quarterly juvenile statistics and you
know them from there you know we have
Mario and Bowser as well we have to make
sure that you know in terms of visuals
they weren't going to lose out they
gotta keep up or gene good to know more
conquering a 10-8 a model that is here
what does it ages and you know another
characteristic of these is that the
posing is very kind of directly linked
with the story and you know what's going
to be happening in the game yeah Mario's
got kind of a humble bow thing going and
Bowser is kind of looking like I own the
world
pretty dapper here though yeah but it is
really amazing the I don't know how
close we can get the camera here we got
a better look here but in person the the
texture where some of them have almost
like a pearlized kind of texture and
there's a lot of subtlety with the
different kinds of fabric you can really
see a lot of nuance for these amiibo
we're looking forward to people seeing
them in person yeah they're gorgeous and
I wonder at this point is there anything
you'd like to share about the
functionality of Bebo for our viewers
amiibo no cannot say any teeth in
costume alternated whatever they study
[Music]
kiki noticed a and so you'll be able to
use the amiibo to get different costumes
within the game and then they'll also
have kind of an assist function we do
have existing amiibo they're supported
as well I think I'll be talking more
about that at a later point but I think
that's all we're allowed to show over
right now enjoy right now I will be
throwing more of this game later on of
course but of course on inquiries on
thank you again so much for joining us
here and cherries for the inside math
development process of the game and
folks who are watching thank you so much
for joining us we're gonna be back in a
few seconds here with our next segment
so please don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
freedom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to in ten no
treehouse live at e3 I'm Sam from the
treehouse and for this segment I'm
joined by my colleagues Reggie and
Teresa so Reggie how you feeling I'm
John great I'm feeling great the
spotlight was as I said direct to the
point the reaction by the fans has been
fantastic I mean certainly super mario
odyssey and and what we showed from that
the little snippet of metroid prime for
had the fans just tremendously excited
and you know it just it continues our
overall message of how we approach III
and what it is that we're trying to do
for us it's all about showcasing content
typically content that's near in so
obviously we showed a little bit of arms
a little bit of splatoon - xenoblade
chronicles - coming later on this year
and we also showed a couple little
snippets of things that are coming a
little bit further further along but so
far the reaction has been fantastic and
it just continues right and that's why
we're here on treehouse live a little
bit more in depth view of the games and
and so so far so good I know we're kind
of in a calm before the storm right now
the floor still isn't open so we can
actually still see the carpet it hasn't
been packed with people yet you've got
to do some exploring around the booth
what do you think of a new dog city come
to life here at e3
you know the booth is fantastic that the
team that we have that works on the
booth design and to look in the field
both from an away perspective as well as
with the the headquarter team at NCL
every year they are outdoing themselves
last year it was the takeover with
breadth of the wild this year it's all
about new donc City and creating an
environment for consumers to really go
deep into the game about half of the
booth is all about
SuperMario Odyssey the other half were
showcasing all of our other content
including third-party content we're
showing FIFA 18 out on the floor
so it's it's a great booth and as you
say this is the calm before the storm
just as I was coming in earlier there
are already thousands of people out
there just waiting to come in and
typically when the doors open it's like
the Running of the Bulls and they all
come crashing into our booth so it's
gonna be fantastic I remember last year
we were down on the ground floor and you
can actually feel the rumble in the
ground when people started coming in
it's gonna be exciting but again you
know for us the the spotlight was a
focus on Nintendo switch games what
people don't understand is that as we
construct our overall presence at e3
we're very thoughtful around what's the
best way the show content and so
Nintendo 3ds is going to play a key role
here on treehouse live
we've got content that we'll be showing
today we've got content that will be
showing really throughout the three days
that we're here and it's important that
the fans at home and our consumers
understand that Nintendo 3ds is still a
vibrant part of our business
obviously with Pokemon ultra Sun Pokemon
ultra moon that was announced last week
that's going to be a fantastic holiday
driver for us we've got other great
games coming and and you know what
people don't realize is that Nintendo
3ds was the only platform that grew last
year in 2016 versus 2015 the only one
and we've sold 66 million globally of
Nintendo 3ds again more than any other
platform in this generation people don't
know that I've got my handy dandy new 2d
SXL and and obviously in continuing to
showcase new hardware you know for us
it's all about continuing to drive that
momentum it's nice that the family keeps
growing now we've got this adorable
little member to add to it as well as
exactly it is it is really pretty and it
it really showcases great I'm playing me
topia right one of the fun things about
my job is I get to play the games early
I'm playing me topia I've got mieze of
mr. aiyah Numa mr. Miyamoto mr. Koizumi
is in there and of course I had to have
bill as a Dark Lord so
so I'm really I'm really enjoying it on
my my new 2d SXL and it's it's fantastic
you can play games you're like it's work
so funny story is I'm playing Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild and putting in
a lot of hours and that I've got my
family saying so you know you're doing
this just for e3 right you're doing this
because you have to be able to show off
and tell people you finish the game bla
bla bla yeah I'm doing it because I
enjoy it and I want to do it and so it's
it's fantastic I have to do this means I
have to play early in the morning or
late at night so but actually just over
the course of e3 um we've hoped you'd
touch a little bit on the tournament
activity we've gone because right below
pretty well absolutely and again the the
tournament activity is a key part of
what we're doing here at e3 three
different tournaments starting off with
splatoon to later on today then we've
got pokken tournament DX we've got arms
hopefully everyone saw how I humiliated
Geoff Keeley playing arms on his show
but that game is gonna really show well
I think from the from the tournament
scene standpoint and for us supporting
the tournament community and and really
driving that that part of our engagement
with our fans is is really important to
us so we're very excited to see how the
three three tournaments play here at e3
I think it's been really fun watching
people play arms and especially watching
high-level competitive players get into
the real meat on the bones of that game
and there's such a level of nuance to
the strategy and the actual technical
ability that I've watched a few folks
where there may be pro smash players or
pro players for another series so they
really are used to getting into the
nitty gritty and into the weeds of the
mechanics and you'll just see their eyes
light up as they start playing arms it's
oh I'm getting this some interesting
depth and flexibility to it and and even
within the office watching who's been
picking which characters they're man's
and how we're gradually sort of growing
as players as we're duking it out
against one another but it's been a real
fun right it's gonna be exciting I'm
really excited to see
the how the players we have showcased
that game how they showcased pokken
tournament as well I saw a little bit of
the the pre-gaming going on and that's
gonna be fantastic so it's it's gonna be
very exciting for us so what else are
you thinking as far as some of us see
titles that we got going on here so you
got a lot to cover we've we've got a lot
I mean you know again everything that we
have on the floor here is showcasing and
showing off fantastically well I'm
pleased to see the third-party support
we've got Rabbids on on our show floor
Ubisoft obviously has that game in their
area that is really fun I've been able
to get my hands on that game that is
really fun to play so it's it's going to
be very exciting we've got Fire Emblem
warriors here on on our booth that game
is showcasing well really everything we
have shows so well and I'm really
thrilled to see what we're doing with
third party as well and if we can jump
to this I think on the subject of cool
titles we've actually got something a
surprise for us I have I have a nice
little surprise right and I said when I
was with Kili that literally within the
first hour of treehouse live we would be
breaking news and and that is what
treehouse live is going to be doing all
through the next three days so we have
some news we have a world premiere of a
new game this is a Nintendo 3ds game
that we'll be launching later on this
year
we're going to play for you the video
for this for this new game and then
Theresa is going to demo it and we've
got the developers who are going to come
talk about it as well world premiere
game announcement on Nintendo 3ds just
for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well surprise I am so excited to
actually talk about this game yes
welcome back everyone to Nintendo
treehouse alive at e3 I'm Audrey I'm
here with Teresa and Tim and we have two
very special guests with us we have
Sakamoto Sanh the legendary creator of
the Metroid series as well as Jose from
Mercury steam so thank you so much for
joining us today and as we just saw
we're gonna take a look at Metroid Samus
Returns so long enough let's jump right
in - yeah let's jump right in to the
start so for the people at home that
aren't familiar with the Metroid
franchise this is intended primarily I
action game it features Samus Aran who
is a renowned bounty hunter and she's
been sent by the Galactic Federation to
Planet sr388 to investigate and
annihilate the Metroid's she's the best
at what she does oh yeah she's super
cool and this is actually a reimagine a
ssin of the original Gameboy classic
that was released in 1991 Metroid to
return of Samus and this game is just
it's beautiful it's a little bit shinier
than they go yeah yes it is and it's
this game is still about discovery and
exploration you know there's intense
boss battles and there's so many
pathways to discover and you can take
your time through it and this is really
this is classic 2d Metroid to a tee it's
got the isolation the exploration and of
course Samus just generally being
amazing yeah and the great thing about
those being on the 3ds is that this
there is so much detail in the
background and it's really heightened
with the 3d feature on and you can't see
it at home right now but it does feel
really really good yeah it sounds cheesy
but it adds a lot of depth to the
experience yeah oh and something I want
to actually show here on the show floor
so in the past Samus was able to aim at
45-degree angles but now she has this
whole range of motion which really
allows for precision here
it's really nice because especially as
you get further into the game they're
enemies all over the place so having the
freedom to shoot anywhere you like is
incredible
yeah so the free game so the free game
here is also really cool here where when
I am actually moving it and I actually
have an enemy on site and target the
CICC you'll audio cue will change and
also that it will highlight it right so
again it allows for a little bit more
precision here and it's still up to you
to aim precisely but that's a nice
visual indicator is just very yeah and
Sam is here has her very basic abilities
and so as I keep exploring and seeing
new environments I'll hopefully gather
new abilities to upgrade my suit so this
is another new ability that Sam has has
in this game it's a melee counter and if
I trim it appropriately and immediately
shoot I have a bet I do a critical hit
on the enemy but in the circumstance
that I don't immediately shoot I have
some time to actually just shoot from
afar and take give give myself a little
bit more leeway to not get hit the
counter is a new ability as you
mentioned and it's really great because
this game gets challenging it's very
very difficult and while we're speaking
about challenges perhaps you could tell
us a little bit about some of the
challenges you encountered while
developing
we really kind of double to the 90s
carry the war game design no matter our
CEO so close in a total mooska she go
tonight yeah well I mean I think I don't
know if it's you qualified it is a big
challenge but something that we face
whenever we're working on it on
something like this with an established
style of gameplay it's adding you know
what sort of new elements can we add to
something that again is established and
has had success in the past company I
know Amanda who stated I get there so
did you get a key to human about because
no he don't need no you know what a
fight oh yes I mean I really felt that
it would be difficult or quickly
difficult to bring in new elements that
would have a lot of excitement and at
the same time make the fans of the
franchise you know happy and satisfied I
know the more calm kind of samos the
details of the quickie monster but you
know I think this time with samus
returns I think we've done a really good
job
I don't know what the Shoshone know
super asleep at all and maybe iodized
and why is that because we found this
really amazing partner to work with
market is team is honest and that's
mercury Steve Hassan you got thought
thank you very much Jose and after we're
speaking you've actually got stamina to
legendary morph ball ability I did and
this is very very handy to get as you
can see through certain tunnels here
here's a safe station which oh great now
I'm gonna keep on going and exploring
this area and here there's this is a
pretty weak area from where I just was
and you'll see this gate here
this is a little different from the
original game yeah it definitely is and
from people that haven't played the
metroid 2 in the past this purple liquid
is actually very painful and I'll just
yeah yeah I can't really go down there
and I want to and I can't really
interact with this right now so I'm
gonna keep on moving forward and see and
that's really that's the nature of this
game is you'll come across areas that
you just can't survive in yet you just
can't get past and you'll have to
acquire new tools and abilities to be
able to keep exploring and keep pushing
forward
exactly so since I couldn't go through
the door I went up and around it so I'm
gonna keep on moving forward and this is
also a brand new feature to the Metroid
franchise these are a on abilities an is
a very mystical and powerful energy
source and they actually give abilities
to Samus that are very different from
the technical upgrades that she gets for
her suit so this one that I just
gathered is called the scandalous and
what it was is that oh I should remind
people that the Aeon abilities are
actually not they're limited you can't
justify them whatever you want to and so
they'll have their own energy and you'll
have to gather power of power-ups for
them and also more energy in order to
refill that tanks can pull yeah so to
showcase the singham pulse if you see
the bottom screen the map usually kind
of of the Explorers once you start
moving but if I use the scan pulse and
then she open up
math already for me and also on the
upper screen will show these box that I
can easily break so now I know that oh
there was an actual hidden path there so
and normally you would just have to
shoot everywhere to try and find
breakable blocks and you can still do it
that way if you want to but if you have
the a on to pull it off but this scan
post is also very very helpful not
everything can be easily broken with
your laser so that's kind of some ammo
that you'd have to waste and it's it's
nice to actually have the an ability to
strategize about now which one am I
gonna use am I gonna use my ammo or am I
gonna use the a on ability in order to
keep on discovering exploring absolutely
and you know throughout her long career
samus has had a lot of unique abilities
at her disposal and as we've seen
already this game adds even more so
Jose perhaps you could tell us a little
bit about the process you guys went
through of adding new abilities like the
melee counter or the Aeon abilities yes
well from the beginning sakimoto-san
continued Christine to challenge
ourselves to the universities so we were
given freedom people to type a little
different idea some mechanics but afraid
within the material universe while this
idea mechanics were discovered it was
just a matter of iterating and polishing
they design they really add a lot to the
experience so good work
so here is an energy station and I'm a
little bit low so I'm just gonna take
that you always want to take advantage
of any of these stations every little
bit of health matters yeah for sure
you'll notice that a beeping started
that's actually my Metroid detector and
it's telling me that there is a metroid
nearby again for people that don't
really know what Metroid's are there are
an alien species that they're pretty
dangerous and they suck up the light
form of any alien species in order to
survive you don't want to hug a Metroid
necessarily yeah exactly
another thing I want to showcase here is
actually the mapping system that this
game has so now that in case they not
able to go through a door because I
don't have the ability to unlock it
which happens a lot yes I have these
pins now that I can just drop it onto
the mat and then that will kind of be my
note for myself that oh I want to
revisit this later once I grab an
ability and maybe I could try it later
and as you mentioned this game is so
much about exploration and going back
and trying to find every square inch of
the map to find all of this mini hidden
secrets so this pin system is actually
very very your Metroid senses are still
tingling so keep searching
keep getting closer because the beeping
is getting a little bit more insistent
nice found a hidden missile tank yeah
let's say there was an example where I
kind of knew already that those fast
what's there but the the scam pulse
would have been very useful right there
to kind of show those box there's
another safe station so area Sam both
told me that that block is breakable but
I can't shoot it so I'm gonna try a
missile instead it's opened and that's a
good point if you ever run into an area
you can't progress past use all of your
weapons yes oh it's a little friend my
friends cousin Metroid but we're
actually not fighting him actually
fighting his first evolution and this is
known the alpha Metroid he looks ice as
friendly as a regular that's it so if I
time it correctly I can actually melee
count to him and it gives me an
advantage to actually hit him for more
damage you also see that he'll drop
these little sparks if I actually hit
those perks
I'll get more replenished ammo
replenishment so in case I end up using
all of my missiles I could always go
around him and try to shoot those
in order to get more pistols and I'll
say I don't know how well the home
audience can hear this but the sound
effects in this game are incredible the
music the atmospheric sounds are just
really great so Sakamoto son perhaps you
could tell us a little bit about what
into went into the development of the
soundtrack for this game scene economist
I have to write do they were Super
Metroid oh no sake no game sound of the
composer study sang Kasim we have two of
the composers who work on Super Metroid
on the team for Santos returns so they
hakuna matata cities on the col du pont
au s neighbors are not there but bakugan
Alamo you are not a terrible caustic OCD
you don't know take us to create and
they've worked on pretty much every
Metroid title since that time doing
music for us and so I really don't have
to say any anything they just go do what
they do and what they do is create great
music lock them up don't ever let them
go whoops
so you made quick work of that alphabet
yes good work is so I'm actually gonna
go return to that gate that I couldn't
get to before
make my way there so in the original
Metroid to whenever you defeated a
certain prerequisite number of Metroid's
the ground would Rumble and then you
would know that you would be able to
proceed to the next area so now in this
game you have these gates and they press
on it and you enter the Metroid DNA that
you have just gathered from the Metroid
you just killed it will enter into this
gate unlock reduce this hazardous liquid
that was killing me before and now I'm
able to get to the next area it's really
cool having this really visual cue of
your progress in the game as well yeah
so now I'm gonna go to a later area in
the game and we've gotten a glimpse of
it a little bit but the 3ds hardware
really goes a long way in bringing this
world to life it helps communicate the
isolation of Samus being stuck on this
alien planet
so sakimoto-san could you speak a little
to how you use to 3ds tech to bring this
world to life and really reimagine it
bah-bah tanaka a twinkie man for a rainy
kono michi no works a family knows
your atacama silicon we mastered our 3ds
you're gonna get it cut there kono sekai
all so go seem a little touch to you but
yeah I mean I do think that with this
title of course with Samus the 3d the
glasses-free 3d the 3d effects are put
to great use it really does help build
the world that were exploring but I like
to go ahead and ask Jose to talk a
little bit about some of the more
technical aspects yes it was very clear
to us from the beginning that if we
wanted to convert to the player the
greatness of the image should have done
it and the past glory of the Social
Security system we had to the provider
be science of a scale thanks to the
death
given by the 3d as capability so we want
it to the flattest from the only the
development process this is going
through the first emissions of ours
hope you've gotten yourself in trouble
Teresa I always do
I ran into his room and he didn't like
that but I'm stuck here and so he gives
me leave and now it's not the time to
play with it necessarily but I would
point out that you also got your spider
ball great that's right and I I also got
bombs here so these are actually very
handy for taking them out with your new
friend this is obviously and that brings
to mind the fact that all of the enemies
actually redesigned for this version so
Jose perhaps you could tell us a little
bit about what the process was for
redesigning the enemies because we
wanted to display the visual design of
the real enemies as as much as possible
and we had to adapt the attachment
behavior so they could fit with other
new pimply and without making them lose
much of the original field in the
process for the Metroid's they were the
star so they saw all of this emotion
original game and this want it also to
be a big shame in our game they well
they suffer massive overhaul from the
mechanics and also we want it to creepy
so the transition in their life on time
I tried to I know that this is something
that is very creative and good thank ya
so I could actually take the spider ball
and the spider ball is actually an
ability here that's very very unique to
metroid 2
but I'm actually gonna do a very hard
technique that I'm not tubing very good
right now I swear I practiced spent
hours trying to get the craziest places
using bump jump oh but I missed you're
trying to work your way around system
app that also brings me to the point
that a lot of the maps have been
pre-designed for the new system so Hosea
can you speak a little to the process of
redesigning the maps as well yeah the
devotee to respect as much as possible
the original game because it has such a
rigid in structuring within the Metroid
series because we want it to be also we
wanted again to be more disposition to
be more dynamic and diverse talent
original game introducing some classic
abilities not other games in the series
but when were not present in the
original game and also we added some new
special abilities that are unique to
this title so the combination of both
made us realized some very interesting
situations regarding level design for
players to actively figure out that way
for war in new ways actually before I
take this elevator I want to show this
this is also a new feature to Metroid
Samus returns and it's a teleport
station it's actually helps a lot with
the mobility of the game where instead
of backtracking all the way through
previous areas you can actually use the
teleport to quickly jump into a new area
and this actually really helps when
you're trying to gather some items that
you weren't able to in the past or
explore new pathways that you weren't
able to before I'm not gonna take it
right now I'm actually gonna go back and
take this elevator to a new area but
you're right it's such a huge addition
to the game being able to more quickly
get to the areas you've already been to
and find all this juicy secrets you
weren't able to get up before oh because
like gathering all these items it
actually rewards you in the end because
it gets it does get more difficult as
you further get into the planet and the
baddies you get really hard so you
definitely want to get all those
upgrades and the items and it rewards
you but you can also choose not to if
you want a challenge so I visited
previous lava rooms before so I know
that this red door looks a little bit
dangerous but I'm gonna go in anyway
just to show a rebel yeah it hurts yeah
I don't want that okay so I'm gonna
actually use the scan pulse because I
see there's something up there
and I'm pretty sure there's a pathway
but just to make sure there you go so
we're gonna go up here I love how if you
had just shot up above you it would have
looked like there wasn't anything to
break yeah it's actually good that you
used to scan polls right there yeah I I
have gotten lost more than once
here's another up suit upgrade I don't
know if how vibrant the colors are it's
just this world is so messy I just know
people yeah
and it's just again it's really cool
when the 3d feature is on because you
get to see all the stuff that's happened
in the background but yeah so I'm going
to go in here
you know Samus has a classic suits so I
can't go here so let's try going back to
the way we keep from I was very close
like to play dangerous and now you can
survive so we're gonna explore this room
now and we could always go back and
explore other lava rooms to see what we
missed that's a point out that this is
all one planet this is all sr388 but
look how different the environments are
it's a big planet oh yeah a lot of
different areas there's a lot of variety
and every every every area is just so
colorful and unique on its own so here
I'm gonna show a new an ability called
lightning armor what it does it gives us
green blood so Samus but also
overcharges my melee and lets me go
through enemies without taking much
damage but it does take away
from my a on and so I want to actually
save any case I need it later yeah every
time you get hit it actually makes your
a on edge go down so we mix just run
this foolishly through a group of
enemies unless you want to feel a lot of
pain yeah so here's another door that
I'm unfortunately not able to get in
through so I'm gonna do another pin here
but I'm also gonna show here there's
this information screen that will
actually see it will show different
items that are shown in the map and if
you're not quite sure what that icon
means will actually tell you here and it
will actually unlock to once you've
discovered it and you know how to
interact with it so definitely keep
keeping an eye on these because these
are actually really brings me to the
question sakimoto-san can you tell us a
little bit about the decision to this
version of the game okay
so stay home I beta so you know this
game is set on sr388 and it's a planet
that was home to the chozo civilisation
at one point and so it it saw the chozo
flourish and it also saw them crumble so
this whole area has this historical
background of being a place just sort of
filled with with lots of riddles
boom man oh-ho shaky there talk sucks
so that's why you see all of these again
Choza ruins as you mentioned throughout
throughout the game city kansas on data
after so no boom bang on Dora
and I think if you you know we have a
chance to play samus returns you might
find some of the answers to the riddles
that the chozo civilisation left behind
there may be some more like intriguing
riddles introduced through the game as
well fine I guess everyone's just gonna
have to wait you've got yourself into
trouble again I did it so this is the
second evolution of the Metroid species
this is the gamma I did I was able to do
a counter melee out on him finally as he
came up close to me but I'm also gonna
use ice beam because it seems to be
really weak - yeah he's he's kind of
dynamics that have moves he's swooping
down on me
he's throwing electricity but that's a
good point if you're ever fighting an
enemy or a boss and your weapon of
choice doesn't seem to be making a big
dent try
try one of your other weapons their
abilities because they might be a little
more successful and since I'm a little
bit low on health I'm gonna feel safer
if I put on my lightning armor so I'm
just gonna go here you've made him mad
yeah he's not happy
I'm just gonna throw this out there this
spider legs are really creepy yeah this
guy's at least turned red though so
you're doing well yes there I should be
almost there
and that's another kind of visual
indicator to show you that you're
getting close to this guy yeah and
there's all those audio cues too for
when when's the right time - oh boy
when's the right time to melee him so it
only happens when he goes down on the
ground but yes I was successfully all
right oh that I actually want to show
another leader area in the game cuz I
think it'd be really cool to show the
fans let's do it
so while you switch to other say file
sakamoto Saanen jose we're hoping you
could tell us a little bit about how you
went about balancing this game because
there's obviously a lot of abilities and
it must have been difficult to balance
making them feel useful to players
without taking away from the challenge
how do you know my juvenilia core or
take to the mall continously Tara Kumari
she - every so no barrel full of Sun or
Ashoka I booked it do you know a
knockout oh so kinda see some of sky
dinosaurs who are you a robot robot
Scotty the negative mass are you
well of course you know it's it feels
great it's an exhilarating to use these
really powerful dime to end dynamic
abilities and you know players want to
use them and we want them to use them of
course
because you see now our atari king joke
about it that is Padano cjgr not gonna
date a come on to your mechanic darwin
but you know one of the things we have
to be careful of is if we you know
overuse them if we make them too
powerful it reduces you know some of the
tension that you feel in the game and it
sort of has the counter effect of
actually reducing the excitement and
sort of again that we want players to
feel so again well yeah i think a good
example of some of the difficulty in
that fine-tuning is what we just saw is
penises is being burst and what's
difficult again about finding that
balance is you have to measure the the
effect of the the the weapon and you
also have to take into fact or take into
consideration the amount of energy uses
and the the supply of energy that's
available to you and trying to come up
with again a balance that works
throughout the game and keeps all of
those factors in mind it can be quite
challenging i think you know we we put a
quite a load on a mercury scheme and
having them do that but i think they did
a remarkably good job there's a tomato
sauce anymore
abilities but only because they can be
used alone but only because they can be
used combination between them and also
they can be combined with a classic
abilities to possi for balance for all
produced aluminium achieved a great
balance and trust me it's still
difficult all right so my Metroid
detector went off again and this is the
gamma husk so pretty sure I'm not gonna
be facing him maybe it's something
cuddlier this is the next evolution this
is the zeta and yeah he's pretty gnarly
I'm in a cycle know the song was saying
that about the bean burst I actually
wanted to showcase this other a on
ability because it is full power it's so
cool and it feels really powerful
they missed my moment to the nail again
so I'm gonna use a combination of
abilities here from missile to grapple
to bean burst you really have to be on
your game with this guy because he
switches up his patterns a lot oh you
know hard to predict any yeah he's hard
to predict and totally aims for me too
he's got me down that's just a beautiful
melee account do too I love how it slows
down time and it was that really
cinematic presentation yeah so feel so I
have bacon action II and I absolutely
love it this is my least favorite this
one gets me every time
oh and now you died on purpose so that
we can see Rose its damage you look so
elegant there beautiful yes thank you I
aim to please
yes all right I'm gonna try this again
yes you can do this we all believe it
I'm gonna skip the cutscene mmm I'm
gonna get right into that
all right oh he was nice enough to give
it to me
I'll take it yeah
the other side so I gotta get shot at
the zoo please
you know he's not invited to your
birthday party anymore I'm not ruined it
I I like know and as a we're showcasing
here the new abilities you're being
burst to their your lightning armor they
add to the experience but as to the
balance they were talking about earlier
they definitely don't make it easier you
have the ion gauge and you can't spam
these abilities at all I mean I think
again it's alright time's the charm
he's pretty strong yeah I'm he's pretty
I'm hopeful that that's the third time I
can get a
[Music]
of course mister he missed him that time
that was lucky
he's gonna feel that tomorrow
hope so so mean
that's your favorite
[Music]
he's more afraid of you than you are a
pen remember that really like a tear I
don't think he cares much about it
you think you have a handle on it he
switches it up oh yeah I know I always
need to be on guard with him because
it's never the same pattern or
consistent at all you're getting really
close to do this alright I can do it I
can do this I believe in you
this is the time and he's not gonna do
that move baby over and over again
how dynamic the bean brush looks it is
and I ran out of me on energy that was
my best got to do the old-fashioned way
now
misil's adieu
oh it's just a melee counter that's
beautiful well that is all we have to
show for game footage but we do have
some cool announcements to also show to
the folks at home alright so as you
probably might have seen in the very
beginning of the game the surface area
amiibo functionality is active in this
game it does support the - Sammis the
zero suit samus and the regular samus
from the Super Smash Brothers line but
there was also two new amiibo that we're
so excited to show you guys so we
actually have them right here actually
no I'm gonna give you the honors because
he's so awesome so you got the Metroid
and this is the best part he's actually
squishy he's actually feels like a
metric yeah and then you also have Samus
again here but she's in her classic
Metroid 2 pose and that is just so so
cool like the amount of detail that's
around her it's just it's so amazing she
feels so cool so yeah things are gonna
be great additions to my collection
maybe York yeah so we we can't
unfortunately tell you what the
functionality is in this segment but we
will announce it at a later time but we
wanted to show you these because they're
so so cool yes and they have any final
thoughts they'd like to tell Erica nanka
happiest I quote on any carry man yes I
wanted to thank sakimoto-san a Nintendo
49 on us and to the below it is new
Metroid
thank you so much yeah I know what
that's touching more I know market is
teaming up this cuckoo pattern on me
right there so the Metro in Okinawa say
oh so he don't get to go to he's only
happy yeah I think you know we were very
happy of course to have come have been
been lucky enough to team up with met
Mercury's team on this project and we
really feel that the world or the
potential for the 2d Metroid franchise
has really just opened up for us a lot
so thank you so much she does a conch I
know somebody turns ever it was cooked
in skin Amano
yeah so we've actually hey everyone
welcome back to GameSpot's III stage we
just finished up the Nintendo Direct
Conference and they played a few games
on Nintendo treehouse life pretty
surprising show overall one of my
favorites personally from e3 so far I'm
Mike McCarty I'm here with Justin hey
Walt hey Lucy James hello and Kelly plug
hi you watch the pre-show then same crew
we are gonna come back and talk about
our predictions and also just about what
I think we all agree was a great show
overall start from the top although I'm
excited to get to a few things later on
you're gonna play with how wrong alright
so
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 is coming out
this holiday yeah
because we'll get to it later but Super
Mario Odyssey is coming earlier than I
think a lot of us thought oh yeah I
thought it was holiday October 27th we
now know for Super Mario Odyssey but
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 they just said
holiday 2017 which is great because I
think we were thinking because those are
two of their bigger you know games
coming out later this year slash next
year we now know they're coming out both
in the fall which is awesome they showed
a lot of it or a little bit of it and
but not anything that like
groundbreaking that I don't think we
seen before I think it shed more light
on characters which I'm not familiar
with in that universe at all no I said
Morrison from Final Fantasy Kingdom
Hearts is I think he's character
supervisors right yeah that would
explain for sure I would have liked a
little less voice acting it was
yeah wasn't my favorite I mean this is
the kind of game I would play with
Japanese voiceover anyway so I'm
assuming that is an option
I sincerely hope so fingers crossed some
of that English voice work was yeah they
showed a lot more of the environments I
think than we previously had seen we
knew this game would be massive if it
was anything like X or the first
Xenoblade Chronicles and then after that
they just quickly showed off a
multiplayer Kirby game it looked like it
almost when they're fighting bosses like
I'm semi familiar with like Kirby games
in general but later on in this demo it
looked like they were it was almost like
a beat him up boss yeah yeah it's like
it's very combat heavy but also
platforming as well see soon four player
co-op mistaken
Kobe Cup head yeah there's looks like
there's you can play it by yourself
still yeah will actually be playing Lucy
you'll be playing this game with it yeah
today tomorrow morrow cool well that
might be on our live stage either way
we'll have that out this week so we'll
get to see more of that what'd you guys
think of this it's exciting
oh it just looks so adorable well I love
Kirby I am I playing crystal shards on
64 and I just I'm excited to have
another Kirby game to play HD Kirby in
particular yeah so cute number the pre
shot I was saying outside of splatoon to
I kind of want a multiplayer experience
for the switch and co-op
platforming Kirby sounds awesome yeah
they really brought what you wanted I
know
Evelyn yes Lee I don't there were not
many things we wanted that they didn't
show um yeah but please okay they were
okay so they didn't let me get let's get
into this actually uh no Virtual Console
news no no mother three news
no animal crossing news no animal
process the deep worse conference ever
they didn't show animal crossing but I'm
kidding
for those where's the whiteboard mister
yeah why below but they did show other
things that we really yeah really did
wine I cried Pokemon I had lots of like
what there yeah a lot of like shocked
noises could the Pokemon RPG just be
stars or I think stars is a code name
like yeah yeah I made it sound like
we're starting development on this
probably in the last couple of months
yeah cuz I said it's being developed so
who knows why we'll see especially with
ultra so
kind of on the closest horizon yeah I
imagine it would be a departure from the
Sun and Moon like from a Lola if they're
doing Ultra Sun and ultra moon so it
would be likely that it would be kind of
on its own or maybe like some sort of
spin-off of things we've seen before
with a Lola I don't know if they would
just rehab I know the rumor was that
stars was going to be the port of Sun
and Moon I don't think that's the case
no they said this is like being
developed specifically for the Swift
yeah I mean which could still be that
wouldn't really support this could I
mean maybe the wording is hazy but I
sounded like from where they said maybe
I'm just hearing this because the rest
of the conference was pretty good Nick
Robinson tweeted like okay how casually
he said this like from behind a desk for
the first time in the series 20 year
history is like oh yeah and we're doing
a console so almost like a throat yeah
flippant yeah very excited for that then
the next thing which is the first of a
couple in this franchise surprises from
it all of a sudden just a little bit of
music and Metroid Prime for idols
greenish like logo came up there was a
lot of excitement was very high it was
like nestled in between Pokemon RPG
casual announcement and Yoshi but here
we got the Metroid Prime for a little
cinematic I like logo menu screen is
kind of thing like they could have
closed with this oh yeah even after as
cool that's what you said you thought
that would happen should have closed
with this yeah cuz what else could it
that have been when you see forward do
you just assume cuz like climb and
corruption were sorry echoes and
corruption weren't numbered they were
called the subtitle so then four is an
odd well departure but it makes sense it
worth Metroid Prime game when you see so
there's like the the space stuff a
couple of hours for like oh is the
Skyrim and then the four came up we
really got the perk menu wow that's
pretty awesome no idea no other details
on that I think people can expect what
it might look like obviously
first-person Metroidvania in a 3d world
but it's super exciting but but it also
for me highlighted a little bit like I
need I want an answer for how Virtual
Console how people will be able to
access the Metroid Prime trilogy because
right now on switch that's not something
you can play and I feel like they'll
they'll have an answer to that
did you all play all three I did back in
the day I actually like that goes more
than a lot of people but I think
corruption is my favorite of the three
honestly the first ones like a classic
but I really like corruption but anyway
although that was awesome I do have to
move on because of time just you
probably know it's a good conference if
I have to move on from Metroid Prime for
Yoshi game like side-scrolling 2d
Sonic's the county knows like it looks
like fez usually fantasy perspective
changes yeah it reminded me of my
nostalgically reminded me of Yoshi's
Story play that game which most people
don't like I spot for it I played the
heck out of Yoshi's Story I do have a
soft spot for that game there is a
little bit of prospective stuff in
Yoshi's woolly world but not to this
extent so it seems like they're kind of
iterating on that but I think oh she's
so adorable I was like I will always be
happy to see Yoshi in the girlfriends
I'll play the hell out of this fireman
warriors we expected to see that they
showed like Marth what else did we see
they showed up a few characters another
game that I will play with the Japanese
be oh yeah boy summer was really bad it
seems like anytime they do like English
voiceovers it's just this really heavy
like regal track playing the whole time
yeah and then voice is coming in with
these really cliched lines yeah I won't
get into this too much but I think it
does have to do if you know not being
able to translate the Japanese tone very
well yeah in some cases that happens
very frequently yep but yeah we expected
to see that and then of course they
brought up Zelda DLC we should we had
the hunch that they might release it
during the show which they did not wrong
but it's coming soon yeah Julie xxx we
there's a few I only wrote down a few
but trial the sword heroes path mode and
the master mode as well as there are a
few other things you know you have like
different equipment now you can upgrade
the master sword I think that's in
master mode but trial the sword is kind
of like that of Cave of trials ish thing
I think I'm venting it's kind of like
Eventide event I'd island but in
Twilight Princess they became a tribe I
think I might be butchering what the
name was but um you know you fight
through different waves you start off
with nothing I'm get to the end I think
that's how you power up you
Master Sword I'm not mistaken but that's
coming June 30th they also showed off
like I predicted actually kind of
champions ballad DLC the next DLC for
this game and that'll be holiday this
year still unclear I told you maybe it's
a prequel when you're playing through
stuff with it's called the champions
ballad because it's me Fudd to rue
Cavalli and our boats are the four
champions that helped link out in the
past before breath of the wild and they
also come into play in the game but we
won't don't forget too much into it but
that would make the most sense because
we allow them to reuse areas without
having to recreate an entirely new zelda
yeah and it also makes sense because
they showed off those amiibo that are
beta yeah those are awesome I really I
don't really I don't normally go all in
for a me bow they showed the Metroid one
later on which is really cool but these
like three or four tme though
so I was wondering if it is gonna be a
prequel or so maybe the amiibo brings
them in his companions that's kind of
grandiose to think about but or just
like new equipment that you'll get when
you put those on I don't know that's do
sorry I do want to point out the Zelda
it's already gone but she's at the front
and center of that oh yeah that's really
interesting to me because if it is a
prequel like I would just like really
like to be able to play as her
especially her ass that's like that kind
of in that area of Hyrule thinking big I
think that's what that DLC would be is
playing as those people but thinking
small maybe they just give you new they
amiibo themselves maybe get a new dress
a series or something or a dress yeah
yeah so that'll be out holiday DLC no
specific release date but then Mario
Rabbids Kingdom battle I know I hate
saying Mario Plus rabbits but that's
what's called Mario Plus rabbits Kingdom
battle they showed off a little more or
at least like Eve came on and yeah yeah
maybe I was just making good with
Ubisoft cuz Ubisoft spent so much time
bringing in Tendo on their stage I don't
know but it was good to see that they're
just so obviously like giving a nod to
it
GameSpot was pretty hyped about this
rocket League yeah and it's
cross-platform so I was talking like
Pete we said it would probably just be
with PC just like so it's also Xbox one
they announced this afterward not during
the post Xbox one and switch people can
play each other oh that's awesome
okay cool yeah cross network support and
then new accessories and cars I don't
think they show the cars yet but they
showed Mario's hat on
the little hat yeah they showed Mauro
sound the traditional rocket League car
the only sad thing about that is it's
not coming until the holiday as well
like that's a yeah I was hoping that
would be closer to now yeah like
holidays 2017 is getting so packed like
we were just talking about it there it's
like you've got all the pathetic stuff
coming out Call of Duty's has its creeds
and now all of the Mario Odyssey like
everything is happening yeah like Red
Dead Yet
push back so we were like oh what thank
god yeah thank God and then but over
October is crazy yeah like three games
alone on October 27th it's uh
Super Mario Odyssey Wolfenstein - one
more big one that I miss it's just the
GPC Assassin's Creed and evil within -
is like - yes before yeah anyway
speaking of another big game speaking of
getting that why just mention Super
Mario Odyssey I showed a lot off I've
made a joke when that started yeah that
- your ex my dumb son to hear me oh it's
Mario this happened in the back Mike's
like oh it's super Mario yeah I was like
that's Mario he's my t-rex all of a
sudden turn around and he's just wearing
Mario's hat remember we were talking
about we wonder what the conceit the
gameplay can see if it's game abhi
apparently you can just among other
things like platformer with a hat and
using it as like a Captain America
shield weapons you can also just throw
it at things and transforming them
including t-rexes bullet bills goombahs
I'm assuming like koopa troopas or
something yeah actual humans yeah you
said it's like praise mimic ability and
inanimate objects like when you rocket
ships yeah what bills all sorts of stuff
yeah
scheme looks maxed unreal it's really
weird but this there's like a specific
dinosaur world it looks like and then
also they showed off toast arena village
which was like a desert like American
Southwest thing but also it's really
cold yeah yeah yeah and then just a lot
of different stuff oh this is cool we're
here on a deal all unadulterated joy
throughout this whole demo yeah it does
look where he is how old we were every
time he transformed into something new
like
in the war room was just freaking out
yeah and now that they show more of that
off I can actually say that GameSpot we
will be playing that and like not too
long like yeah so they'll be back here
after we close out this and talk to a
few other people and then the next
Metroid announcement Metroid Samus
Returns which is a reimagining of
Metroid 2 return of Samus on Gameboy so
it's also by Mercury steam who if you
don't know did boards with castlevania
lords of shadow one and two and the 3d s
title mirror of fate so it's kind of
good yeah I was like a 2.5 D side
scroller Metroidvania this is coming on
September 15th and they played this for
about half an hour on the treehouse live
like if you want to go check that out
again we'll have that up they played a
lot of it from the treehouse we thought
it might be like a throwaway not
throwaway but we thought it might be a
minor 3s title they're announcing again
it's not brand new but it's a remake so
it's not just the port from a gameboy
game that'd be impossible to port to 3ds
it looked really fun wouldn't work as
well right because that was a really it
worked great on Gameboy at the time but
right now like its skills now and it
fits the game boy like this you have to
reimagine that game this is the perfect
one to do it because it was so different
than the other Metroid right and then
yeah Reggie and treehouse showed this
off during the treehouse live and then
they kind of cut we cut back here and
now here we are and I think I didn't
think I'd be saying this but like I
think Nintendo is my favorite conference
this whole week it's a toss-up between
Bethesda and Nintendo but says des with
that focus on 2017 like that was so much
hyped so much excitement yeah I love the
Nintendo stuff but the fact that I don't
have dates for when this Pokemon game is
coming when when some of this stuff is
gonna come out and that I didn't get
mother for mother 3 no earthbound cycle
my daily my takeaway was a Nintendo
definitely knows what people want though
and they want Smash Brothers either
that's crazy to me but they're bringing
two ways happy like it's it's we don't
know when it's gonna happen and if it'll
be anytime soon which probably won't but
it's coming back he's coming back he's
coming back I will call I will call Rob
everything here will come out before
death stranding kabali
yeah poke you like nothing about the
Pokemon RPG but it's being developed for
the switch I'm jelly I'm just happy they
confirmed
that oh no I like Bethesda I just like
Bethesda games in general yeah that was
a good conference me I think Ubisoft was
really strong yeah I think the pacing of
Nintendo was a little odd points um
super abrupt ending the Pokemon thing
reminded me of the most recent reveal
and attack on Titan where it was just
kind of like this throwaway thing it was
just so weird how how that was done
of course I'm super happy about it but
it was ya know the pacing and delivery
was weird in a lot of places I think the
content was good for Nintendo so I don't
know I think between those three those
are like the big yeah I did kind of miss
sort of the irreverent Nintendo humor
that they usually put it I mean anything
they had was like oh when did this
Master Sword get here but like Reggie
walking through be like if it's not fun
why bother
how is it a game made that a little
happier I guess yeah yeah but I
personally like between what they did
announce with release dates oh yeah and
what they told us that they are working
on I could not have been happier
honestly I don't have a mother 3 itch
like you do major Animal Crossing person
when you say smashed you talk about the
Wii U smash a deluxe version yeah yeah
like they had the amiibo that just came
out I was really expecting them to to
have the switch version because right
now why would anybody buy those unless
you're already invested in that Wii U
version right I know that opportunity
yeah it would have to be a deluxe
version because the development cycle
for smash games is so long right yeah I
mean they had a great success with Mario
Kart yeah I'm surprised they didn't they
didn't even confirm anything yeah
definitely any last thoughts on Nintendo
I smash deluxe I know is coming it has
to I'm surprised it didn't come out here
but overall that's what there was a fun
conference it shows the like how you can
have a press conference and it doesn't
have to be on a stage in front of tons
of people you can just do a quick
presentation show off some cool stuff
and get out yeah yeah you don't need
flames on the stage you don't need
flames on the technical difficulties and
stuff like that I think yeah I think
the succinct Ness of it was also a plus
I mean like we were expecting maybe like
fewer things than actually came out
because it was so short that's why I
think I like Microsoft he's got right
through 42 games I mean like that's I
think that was a strength actually I
mean I was worried that oh they're only
gonna be doing this for 30 minutes but I
think I think that worked and yeah like
you said I there's a lot of great things
that I'm really looking forward to that
we got that were getting very soon
definitely
I like the self-awareness of it when
they said when we were releasing the
switch we hoped people would take it out
yeah they did thank God he said like
I've been buying it and playing and
loving our games I felt and we thought
you can say lated or like like I was at
a translation thing but no I think he
actually meant it because the switch so
far has been kick-ass and we all like it
there was a real like self-awareness of
thank God
the gamble paid off and yeah now we know
that you want games and we're gonna show
you stuff that's gonna come out in the
next year yeah which are great yeah
definitely that was nothing but happy so
we're gonna finish up our Nintendo post
show right there if you want to you
missed it or like missed anything you go
back and watch it later on on youtube or
a twitch channel or a game spot but we
do have more demos coming throughout the
day although press conferences are done
from the major players we are gonna have
things like all those Nintendo games you
just saw Ubisoft games Lucien I'll be
hosting a lot of stuff Kelly and Jeff's
will be back on the stage in a little
bit we'll have phil spencer from x-box
coming to talk to us about the xbox one
x but for now you can go catch up with
all our news from all these games coming
out on GameSpot calm and we'll see you
when we go alive next